un campus de six bâtiments hébergeur de
données c'est la promesse du thésée
datacenter d'aubergenville un projet
élaboré depuis 2013 qui sera
complètement opérationnelle en 2028 la
construction a démarré en février 2020
cette année bien sûr on a été arrêté à
cause de la crise du coc vide il sera
opérationnel au deuxième trimestre 2021
nous aurons cinq autres bâtiments donc
au total six bâtiments pour une
puissance totale de 18 mégawatts sur ce
campus d'aubergenville pour absorber une
telle quantité de données
le projet repose sur de la très haute
technologie afin de réduire les coûts
des entreprises engagées l'approchent
principal de datacenter qu'on appelle un
datacenter nouvelle génération c'est à
la fois d'avoir un niveau de sécurité
disent militer très important mais en
même temps une empreinte
environnementale très amélioré notre
datacenter consommera 30 % d'énergie en
moins par des technologies que nous
avons mis en oeuvre de free cooling par
exemple mais également de l'intelligence
artificielle comme nous utilisons pour
optimiser des rendements de nos
équipements un campus 100% français
soutenu par le département des yvelines
et la commune d'aubergenville
aujourd'hui la grande majorité des
hébergeurs sont des hébergeurs anglo
saxons et nous sommes
nous avons créé ce projet afin
d'apporter une réponse française avec la
souveraineté des données pour
aubergenville ce projet data center
c'est la promesse d'industrie d'avenir
sur le territoire nous sommes chez nous
et les données françaises restent en
france et ça c'est un sujet très
important pour le devenir et la sécurité
de nos données
un futur centre qui coûtera au total
plus de 10 millions d'euros auprès
duquel six entreprises se sont déjà
engagés